how we approach our communication and
how we approach others when we're
nervous about our communication can make
a tremendous difference in feeling
confident and portraying that confidence
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast I am really
excited today to chat with Kelly
McGonagall Kelly is a lecturer at
Stanford GSB who teaches a class on
presentation and communication skills
for academics she is also the
best-selling author of The Willpower
Instinct the upside of stress and her
latest book is the joy of movement how
exercise helps us find happiness hope
connection and courage
welcome Kelly thanks for being here I am
super excited to get time with you oh
thank you for
I know we have a lot to talk about I
think we have a lot of common passions
absolutely so let's go ahead and get
started you have so many interesting and
exciting areas that you look into and
explore I look forward to talking about
all of them but I'd like to start where
I first came to know you and your work
like millions of people and I mean like
29 millions of people I watched your Ted
Talk how to make stress your friend
we've addressed the topic of anxiety
management and communication several
times on this podcast and I'm just
curious to get your take on how we can
manage anxiety and leverage the benefits
that it has for our communication oh
leverage the benefits of anxiety for
communication okay well let me start by
saying I'm someone who is born anxious
so I come to this sincerely and in a bit
of desperation right it's not when those
people was like oh I've never been
nervous and therefore I'll teach other
people how not to be nervous it's more I
know what it's like to have a panic
attack so let's figure out how to stay
engaged with life even when anxiety is a
part of your life and I'd say so since
you said the benefit of it I think that
for me what I have come to Value about
anxiety is it's a sign that I care
so you know for example when I start to
feel anxious now I will say to myself my
heart is in it which is a kind of a
mindset reset you know I can feel my
heart pounding maybe or I feel other
stuff happening in my body and saying my
heart is in it is a way of embracing
that one of the reasons I have anxiety
is not because my nervous system is
broken or you know I'm a a person who
just can't face life I have anxiety in
moments that matter where I recognize
that something is at stake and I want to
contribute or I want to do my best I
want to serve I want to enjoy life when
you come to value that anxiety is a
signal of meaning often or a signal of
caring then the benefit is in staying
wholehearted so that in that moment I
don't have to say to myself Kelly if you
don't calm down you're going to blow it
or Kelly why are you anxious yeah what's
wrong with you I don't have to get into
that self-talk I can instead double down
on the caring I can think about who and
what I care about why this matters to me
maybe I can imagine the best possible
outcome and then I can also use the
energy that often comes with anxiety
I've come to recognize anxiety as a
physical state that actually really does
serve me when I am in a role that I'm
meant to be in so for example teaching
if I don't get anxious before I teach a
class I mean any Class A Class I've
taught a thousand times before if I'm
not feeling anxious right before it or
even when I'm walking over to teach it
there's something wrong it's almost like
I'm dissociated from the fact that this
is what I was born to do I prepared
really hard for it I really want to
connect with my students if I'm not
feeling that something's off because
I've learned that I can actually trust
myself to use that energy I know that
that energy like my body is now a
vehicle for it and that comes in part
from practice a lot of practice a lot of
preparation and then this developing
self-trust I really like how you
literally embody the notion of greeting
your anxiety and the Mantra that you
know my heart's in it is so powerful
because one of the first signs people
report is their hearts pounding and it
distracts them but if you Embrace that
and say hey this means that this I care
about this and it even extends to I care
about the audience that I'm in front of
and I hear you about getting nervous
about something that's important and how
it it Clues me into this is Meaningful
for me and I also get nervous before I
teach and I now look for it like you do
and if I didn't have it it ever happened
like once or twice I've had a class
where I was feeling kind of numb before
and man that things did not go well
right it's either one I've done before
or something was distracting and you
missed it wasn't there yeah it wasn't
present for it and that's even another
way to reframe it that sometimes my my
anxiety is a sign of presence which is
so different from how people typically
think of presence as being very calm you
know I actually love the energy of
anxiety when it's that right combination
of adrenaline and endorphins and
dopamine we love this feeling people do
all sorts of things to try to get that
chemical cocktail of adrenaline and
dopamine and endorphins you know by
paying attention to my physiology and
other activities I love like working out
I realize it it feels very physically
similar so I just have to give myself a
goal like anxiety is not as great in
situations where I have nothing to do I
will be honest about that when it's
worrying about the future and there's
nothing I can do or I'm on an airplane
and I clearly can't fly it like anxiety
in those moments I have other coping
skills for but since you asked
specifically about speaking or that kind
of performance no that's exactly right
and I think it's that reframing that
these are the normal physiological
symptoms that in many cases we seek out
and enjoy I think about first dates or
exciting conversations and we're doing
the same thing but we frame them as hey
this is a great thing I really like that
you and I both teach communication
skills at the GSP in fact as part of the
covid emergency plan that was put in
place here you and I were backups for
each other if one of us got really sick
this is a smart policy by the way I
actually think that was pretty good that
we got in the habit of doing that right
yes that was well it was just stress for
me that I knew somebody as competent as
you could step in although I do have to
admit I got a little nervous that my
students would like you more than me if
I Disappeared I'm curious what do you
find are the most common mistakes you
see our students and those you coach
when it comes to communication yeah so
first of all let me set the context I
work primarily with PhD students who are
all doing amazing research so they're
used to communicating their research in
academic settings and my class is to
help them communicate in every setting
professionally at conferences but also
to the media and to potential
collaborators and stakeholders and
random person on the street and I would
say that the thing that I say over and
over again and we do all of these
exercises to try to practice it and yet
it's really hard for them is to talk
about crunching details not abstractions
so I don't want to know that you study
the technological interface of emotions
and artificial intelligence in market
analysis of blob like basically string
of nouns and I'm waiting to like okay
would you point to something that you
actually study like for example a dating
app okay great and what problem are you
trying to solve how to get people better
matches or something like that and so
I'm always saying like show me the
actual thing show me the question you
ask people in your study take a picture
of people doing the thing that you study
even if what you're doing is modeling
and you never leave your computer go out
into the world and take a picture of the
thing you're that you're modeling so
that I understand so I say that's the
the biggest thing we work on I talk
about coming up with artifacts for your
research the photos the videos the audio
samples the objects that will help
people understand what you do and using
language that people will immediately
understand I think the other mistake is
the mindset that a lot of academics have
in part because they're terrified
getting a PhD is basically understanding
that you don't know anything and people
are eager to point that out to you so
people get in this habit of feeling like
they have to prove that they know stuff
hide that they don't know stuff and also
persuade you that their research is
correct so a lot of times in research
presentations or Communications my
students will
try to like talk fast and deliver things
so fast you can barely keep up so you
can't interrupt with critiques and I
don't want to take questions because the
questions might reveal what I don't know
there's this idea that like my job is to
just sort of push my research at you
and get through it without there being
any kind of critical dialogue and what I
always say is the purpose of any really
interesting communication should be for
the other person to have interesting
thoughts in their own head about your
work it's not to convince them that your
work is right or important or that you
know everything about it you want the
person who is listening to you or
watching you to think wait what if this
or I wonder if or I don't think so the
degree which they are having their own
interesting spontaneous thoughts and
questions that's the measure of success
it really reframes like what you're
doing and how you do it those are two
things we spend a lot of time talking
about wow so there's a lot there I
really like that the goal is to have
people have their own experience about
your content
absolutely and and not only does that
invite collaboration rather than
Challenge and threat it also forces you
I think to be audience Centric my goal
is to have you have an experience rather
than me just push all that information
we do all that I teach empathic design
for talks what do they need to know when
do they need to know it what do they
need to see what do they need to like
literally visually see when do they need
to be able to interrupt that it really
is from that that point of view and it's
not this is not just for academics
anybody is in that same position I coach
and teach Executives and managers who
feel like they don't want to be
threatened and challenged they just want
to push out their decrees and move
forward it's the same things tell them
is if there are problems with your work
people already know it's so funny I I'll
see students like they'll say something
kind of interesting and I'll be like
wait a minute that was so fascinating
like I'm remembering that this woman in
my class had mentioned that she
calculated stuff with a certain
15-minute window during market trading
it was a very specific I was like that's
so interesting why that 15 minute window
and tell me more about that she's like
well I kind of rushed through that
because I didn't want anyone to ask
questions about it I was afraid that
maybe it was like the wrong choice I'm
like no this is that you made a choice
right is interesting and it almost
doesn't matter if it's the perfect
choice
I want to know that you made a choice I
want to hear why you made the choice I
want to be able to have an opinion about
your choice I think that that particular
example is really important and
resonates nicely with some of the things
we've talked about when we've talked
with folks who are experts at improv
make a choice commit to the choice be
behind that choice and be willing to
accept what consequences come from that
choice and I don't want to lose what you
said earlier about this notion of help
people actually see what you're talking
about and that is so critical it is so
easy to hide behind slides and data but
if you can actually have people help
people have an experience of what you're
talking about and it can be with data
too so I'm always saying like you know
if you've got videos of babies doing
funny things because you study infant
cognition show the baby videos but also
if what you've got is data or a model
you know what people always do is they
put it all up there and they're like as
you can see X next I'm like no right you
don't say as you can see right you walk
me through it what you're looking at
here is this notice this like you zoom
in you interpret it this dot this slope
whatever this means this as you can see
it's different from that like you want
people to actually see it so it can be
photos and videos or it can be data but
the idea that somebody can understand
something just because their eyes see it
on a slide that's so different from
somebody having an actual understanding
and an opinion about it oh absolutely
and and it takes them outside of
themselves and puts them in their
audience's perspective and I just want
to get meta for a second and not not
Facebook but you you'd have done a great
job and the answer to that question of
doing exactly what you're talking about
you helped show us and have a give us an
experience of it you are an excellent
Communicator yourself both in writing
and speaking I'm wondering if you can
share a bit about your process what do
you do as you're thinking about crafting
your communication
I always start with the best possible
outcome for the audience
that I care about most right so you
never control everyone who's in the room
or everyone who reads you know the op-ed
that you write or or the book that you
write so I'm always thinking well who am
I really trying to speak to or reach
and what's the best possible outcome for
them do I want them to feel a certain
way do I want them to change their
behavior in a certain way
and then I work backwards and I think
what do they need to hear what do they
need to do
what story could I tell that would make
that outcome more likely and you know
I'm often like literally just writing
this stuff down I'm writing that out and
I start to get ideas for Content blocks
and this would be true if I was drafting
a chapter for a book or giving a keynote
and I'll often think what are these
content blogs like what's the best story
that I have what's the the best case
study I have what's the best scientific
study I have you know I really learned
to put things in judiciously and that it
only has to be one I only have to tell
one story for an idea I only have to
share one study wow so to get back to
the first part of what you said that I
find so cool is you you actually
backward map you start with what's the
outcome and what are the steps that I
need to get there for teaching too right
that's how you design a class absolutely
we haven't talked about that before but
it's really interesting to start with
what's the end and then what do I need
to add to it and you are adding things
very judiciously just one key example
you know many of our listeners know that
for decades I've found great benefit
from doing the martial arts and I know
you're a big believer in exercise and
movement not just in communication but
in life in general and your newest book
The Joy of movement is a testament to
that idea I'm curious if you could just
share why exercise is so important not
just for health but for life and and I
saw in the New York Times that you've
got joy exercises and I'd like to hear a
little bit about that we all need a
little more joy in our lives people
listening
I just did a joy move when you said that
let's let's go backwards let's start
with the joy workout like so one of the
things I tell my students is always
start in the middle of the action like
like start your talk with something
interesting and specific so often people
start with like these General vague
things It's gotta be like an action
movie actually so okay so let me when I
explain the joy workout you will
understand how I think about movement so
the New York Times called me up and they
were like you know we've got all these
seven minute workouts that are based on
getting your heart rate up or like using
all your muscles in a specific way and
we were curious would it be possible to
create a workout specifically to make
people happy and I was like why Yes
actually I do it 10 times a week what
they ended up doing was asking me to
leverage the science of what we know
about what Joy looks like and feels like
in the body and can you teach people to
move in those ways so that it actually
makes them happier more optimistic
feeling more connected more celebratory
and it's based on this this fascinating
research that when people are in
situations where they are dynamically
happy like you get good news and just
imagine what would you do when you get
good news people pump their fists they
throw their arms in there they jump up
and down what would you do if you saw
someone that you that you love but you
haven't seen in years you fling your
arms open wide you like lift your face
to the heavens there are these gestures
that people do or even if you think
about like an athlete who just did
something amazing in a game right they
pose they show off they do their happy
dance
so it turns out that these movements are
really similar all over the world in
lots of different cultures it seems to
be a natural expression of joy
so I developed this workout where you
just like jump for joy and celebrate and
Sway and bounce show people what it can
look like but you do it your own way we
put it to happy music designed to also
make people feel better and you know by
the end of eight minutes the idea is you
can move your body in ways that get your
heart rate up that are good for you
physically but you did it not as like a
punishment for what you ate or not
because you're afraid of some disease
you might get in a decade or giving a
presentation yeah or it's but you you do
it because you can have a direct
experience in movement that you value
and you know the research is really
clear that people who are more
physically active in an activity they
enjoy they're happier they have better
relationships they have more meaning in
life I would love for all of the people
we work with to experience that joy in
their communication but also in just
life in general I find your approach to
both mind and body Minds said in
physical movements really empowering and
so helpful
before we end I'd like to ask you the
same three questions I ask everyone who
joins me are you you up for that yes all
right I saw a big smile everybody if you
were to capture the best communication
advice you have ever received as a five
to seven word presentation slide title
what would it be
I think this is going to be
unusual
my honest answer is trust that people
are adequate
to their experiences that was eight
that's all right I'll let you go help me
understand what that means trust that
people are adequate to their experiences
so this was something that I was taught
by a zen teacher
talking about how we show up for other
people and
how important it is particularly when
you're trying to help someone
that to be present with them in a way
that can hold the Opposites of both you
might be suffering right now you might
be overwhelmed you might have health
challenges and whatever the situation is
and I want to help
and also to have some kind of core
belief
that because you're human
and because this is your reality you're
adequate to this moment there's
something in you
that is adequate to the moment of your
life and this is something that it's a
matter of trust or faith it's a kind of
a putting a trust in the audience as
well that it's their their life it
revolves around them and I'm just here
in a moment of interaction
and often before I give a talk I'll even
think like all right
I just hope that I say or do something
that somebody here needed to hear that's
a lovely Mantra as well I found myself
getting hung up on the word adequate
because to me adequate means minimally
acceptable but in the way you're using
it it's very different and it's an it's
an adequate and confidence nobody wants
to be adequate but I think what it is is
it we're saying is people often
desperately feel that they're not
adequate to this moment I'm inadequate
to this I can't handle this this is too
much and I know what that feels like
like I have that voice in my head too
so there's something about it's a kind
of acceptance absolutely and it's also
removed some of the pressure that I
don't have to be great let me ask you
the second question and I'll be very
curious to hear your answer who is a
communicator that you admire and why so
this will be somebody that most people
don't know but I'll try to describe her
well enough that you appreciate her her
name is Natalie Goldberg so Natalie
Goldberg is an author and also a zen
teacher and she has a really strong
accent like a deep strong powerful voice
and so she sounds very distinct and then
what she says when she talks is like
just
absolute ruthless authenticity this is
how it is this is my experience the the
details there's just something so
grounded about it and I will listen to
her talk about anything
because she'll tell you the color of the
carpet but because she'll tell it to you
because it means something I don't know
it's like the opposite of abstractions
and yet she's so um in touch with what
it means to be human that everything
that that comes out of her teaching and
her writing I just feel like it reminds
me of common Humanity I think a
communicator that we admire who inspires
us and challenges us to change or at
least reflect on who we are is is the
right kind of Communicator what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe I have
an answer that actually has three parts
that I didn't even have to make up for
this okay this is something also that I
teach in my communication class and also
when I coach people giving Ted Talks
this is an idea that I learned from Gail
Larson who teaches a speaking style that
I I really admire it's really about like
viewing speaking as an opportunity to
change people's lives and she says that
there are three sort of sides of
yourself that you can show in any talk
one is the face of wonder which is
really it's curiosity it's
open-mindedness it's what you wonder
about it's what what motivates you the
second is the face of creative fire and
it's what you're passionate about it's
your drive it's all of your time and
your energy made manifest in showing
that you care
and then the third is my favorite which
I don't I don't know how often I get to
do it but it's rude magnificence and
that is when you realize there's
something that people need to hear that
might be difficult
and you know it because of your lived
experience or the wisdom that you have
acquired through your own suffering and
adversity or because you've been willing
to look and think about something for a
long time do you have an opportunity to
say something that feels important and
true
that is yet you're the one who can say
it you're the one in the room who has
thought about this the most or you have
a unique life experience to share
well I would expect no less from a
communication teacher to share three
really powerful ingredients so the
notion of curiosity passion and what I'm
going to call authentic wisdom
well Kelly this has been a true joy and
pleasure for sure I have always admired
what you teach and how you teach it and
the passion that you bring and it's been
a true pleasure to chat and I'm I'm
hoping that people take away that
there's so much value into reflecting on
our communication on our physical
well-being and the joy that we can bring
to others so thank you thank you
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams
for more information and episodes visit
[Music]
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
find us on social media at Stanford GSB